time to hand over to you because you're
going to announce this year's winner
thank you very much I get evening
everyone I hope you're all enjoying this
evening early sports awards it is a real
honor to be nominated for these awards
we've got a lot haven't said athletes in
team bridge and obviously parents and
coaches and peers are here tonight so
I'm sure they're all really proud of you
to be nominated on this occasion and
I've also been given the honor to
announce the overall Sports Personality
winner this evening and I wish you all
the best of luck in all your careers to
everyone that's been nominated and
shortlisted because it is a massive
owner so tonight without further or do
the overall winner of the team bridge
Sports Personality awards tonight is my
fight again it wasn't my idea no idea
that was all Nikki's idea we thought of
a way to try and get you and we managed
to do it yes let me get your trophy and
award Oh guys again leave twice I should
have known I saw the trophy in the
corner congratulations Natalie male more
you're the overall sports personality of
a winner for 2011 it's the first time I
believe in history I'm looking off
camera on getting an odd that anyone has
won it twice in a row how do you feel
and annoys like you've got me again but
thank you very much and firstly well
done to everybody who's nominated
because team wrinting which we are
really lucky to have a lot of talented
sports athletes had the pleasure of
meeting jakarta m at another North Hill
Awards so a lovely girl and best of luck
with everything and with your world
championships I know they're coming up
for you soon so yeah thank you very much
and I'm gonna get you back one day
it's going to be a given that i'm going
to wait for it to be a surprise so thank
you amazing got your license thank you